parce que je veux vous poser deux ou trois questions.
Je pense que nombreux sont ici, et de manière générale dans les pays occidentaux,
ceux qui seraient d'accord avec votre affirmation
que les systèmes démocratiques deviennent dysfonctionnels,
mais en même temps, nombreux sont ceux qui trouveraient
troublante l'idée qu'une autorité
non élue, sans aucune forme de supervision ni consultation
décide de l'intérêt national.
Quel est le mécanisme du modèle chinois
qui permet aux gens de dire qu'en fait
l'intérêt national comme on le définit chez nous est erroné ?
EXL : Eh bien, le politologue, Frank Fukuyama,
a qualifié le système chinois « d'autoritarisme réactif ».
Ça n'est pas tout à fait exact, mais je pense que ça en est proche.
Je connais le plus grand institut de sondage
de Chine, d'accord ?
Savez-vous quel est leur plus gros client ?
Le gouvernement chinois.
Et non pas seulement le gouvernement central,
mais aussi le gouvernement municipal , le gouvernement provincial,
et même les mairies de quartiers.
Ils mènent des enquêtes d'opinion tout le temps.
Êtes-vous satisfait de la collecte des ordures ?
Êtes-vous satisfait de la direction générale du pays ?
Donc en Chine, il y a une autre sorte de mécanisme
pour être attentif aux demandes et aux opinions des gens.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'il faut qu'on se libère
de la pensée selon laquelle il n'y a qu'un seul système politique --
élections, élections, élections --
qui puisse faire en sorte d’être attentif aux opinions des citoyens.
En fait, je pense que les élections n'engendrent plus
de gouvernements attentifs dans le monde.
(Applaudissements)
BG : Ils sont nombreux à être d'accord apparemment.
L'un des attributs du système démocratique
est l’espace d’expression attribuer à la société civile.
Et vous avez illustré, chiffres à l'appui,
le soutien dont le gouvernement et les autorités bénéficient en Chine.
Mais vous avez mentionné d'autres éléments
tels que, les grands défis, et il y a bien sûr
une grande quantité de données qui vont dans un autre sens :
des dizaines de milliers d'agitations et de protestations
et des protestations sur l'environnement, etc...
Ainsi, votre discours pourrait laisser entendre que le modèle chinois
n'offre pas d'espace en dehors du Parti
pour que la société civile s'exprime.
EXL : Il y a une société civile dynamique en Chine,
qu'il s'agisse de l'environnement ou de toute autre chose.
Mais elle est différente.
Parce que, selon les définitions occidentales, une société civile
doit nécessairement être indépendante ou carrément dans l'opposition
au système politique,
mais ce concept est étranger à la culture chinoise.
Depuis des milliers d'années, une société civile existe
bien qu'elle soit compatible et cohérente
et fasse partie d'un ordre politique, et je crois
qu'il faut y voir là une grande différence culturelle.
BG : Eric, merci d'avoir partagé avec TED. EXL : Merci.